I believe I have this opinion whether it
was Barack Obama or george bush or
whomever that presidents are elected for
four-year terms here's a president with
a quarter about a quarter of his
presidency left and the Constitution and
the framers made it very clear what
presidents should do and Supreme Court
justices happen and what the Senate
should do and so I believe that this is
something that should be acted on right
now and that leaving a Supreme Court
justice seat vacant for more than a year
is unacceptable I'm hoping and I know
this hope might be in vain that the
republican-controlled Senate allows this
president to nominate a justice holds
hearings and votes on that justice and
there and and and and provides their
consent as as they see fit you know
people ask me to speculate about what
the president is going to do who he
might nominate and i usually don't
indulge in speculation he is the
president nited states i am the united
states senator from New Jersey I think
that this is going to be a time where
he's going to bring to this decision
solemn anak wisdom because I think
President Obama is good at evidencing
that in trying times we could have a bit
of a constitutional crisis here we could
have a bit of a public a fight along
jagged partisan political lines so I
think he's gonna evidence leadership and
that's what I would expect from any
person who is the president of the
United States of America and I'm hopeful
that we can find a way through this so
that we get someone on the Supreme Court
as soon as possible because there was
really serious consequential issues
before the court well if we waited a
year number one I think that that again
is violative of the Constitution and the
intent of this process and how it was
framed and those people who are strict
constitutional
and I hear people on both sides of the
aisle quoting the framers and what their
intentions were often it is wrong to
wait more than a year with that vacancy
and it does have a real impact the court
has real cases tough cases before them
right now everything from affecting to
how people organize unions all the way
to issues facing campaign finance to
voting rights so I just think that we
need to get the full complement of nine
there as quickly as possible so that we
can deal with the business of our
democracy